in Texas Democrats are turning to the
satanic temple to help them strike down
a law that limits the number of babies
who can legally be killed through
abortion in California education
officials are instructing students to
chant prayers to the demon gods of the
Aztecs who also practiced child
sacrifice in Washington D.C Joe Biden
himself has fully changed his views on
abortion coming out in favor of
infanticide and effectively renouncing
his Catholic faith
a lot of Americans want to keep religion
out of politics
but that is not possible because every
single political issue ultimately boils
down to religion there can be no
neutrality The Divide is less about
right and left than it is about right
and wrong
and the craziest part of all of it is
that the libs can't see it
they are right now at this very moment
siding with literal satanists and Aztec
demon gods they are making the defense
of literal child sacrifice their top
political priority and they don't even
realize they're doing it because the
devil's finest trick is to convince
people that he doesn't exist I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from BLD Who quotes
leftists says leftists say the poor
people too we must fight for the lower
class also leftists life is literally
not worth living if you're poor yes they
are saying that if you're poor if you're
not going to live in a nice fancy house
in the suburbs if you're gonna have any
problems in life it would be much better
for you to be killed not not great
pretty crazy stuff almost as crazy as
this economy right now well if you want
to hedge your Investments against
inflation I would strongly recommend
acre gold if you want to start investing
in physical gold but you do not think
that you can come out of pocket all at
once you know physical gold is expensive
have no fear acre or gold will let you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
thirty dollars a month before you call
me a liar
hold on let me explain how it works you
pay each month once your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house they've also got a new 100 a
month subscription to a five gram gold
bar so if you want to up the ante you
can
I've really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals I've really
enjoyed investing in acre gold they keep
you updated on your stash each month
they ship once you hit that threshold
you get it all safe and sounded in your
hands great hedge on inflation visit
getacregold.com null start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this URL because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient mentioned at get underscore
acre that's getacregold.com Knowles
thank you acre gold for supporting the
show we have a lot more to get to we've
got to get to
ridiculous fake news about Ivermectin
we've got to get to fake news about
healthy quote-unquote young people dying
from the Coronavirus
we need to begin with the child
sacrifice stuff that's a sentence I
didn't I never thought I would say I
didn't hope that I would ever say that
we have it it is crazy
because
the left
knows not what it does it doesn't it
can't see it but but if you're outside
of that bubble if you're outside of the
liberal establishment you look at this
and you think guys you're you are
actually siding with real full-on
satanists and Aztec demon gods and you
don't and they said no you don't get it
it's it's so clever oh it's no you don't
unders it's not really
satanists that we're siding with except
it is so here's a representative article
in the hobbington post
satanic temple floats devilishly clever
strategy to dodge the Texas abortion law
oh it's devilishly clever what's what is
devilishly clever what are they doing
well
they've got this new strategy they're
going to say that taking an abortion
drug is an important part of their
religious ritual it's a Sacrament in the
satanic temple quote a lawyer for the
massachusetts-based temple sent a letter
to the Food and Drug Administration
earlier this week to request that the
church be allowed access without
prescription to the abortion inducing
drugs mifa pristone and misoprostol as
part of its sacramental abortion ritual
he compared employing the drugs to the
use of peyote in certain Native American
rituals under the religious freedom
restoration act for the temple bodily
autonomy and science or sacrosanct and
the abortion ritual is an important
expression of those beliefs explained
Temple co-founder Lucian Greaves who oh
how clever wow gosh we didn't see that
one coming what the satanists are saying
is that abortion is their
Central sacrament
just like we've been saying
for decades for decades Peter craff
who's a wonderful uh Theologian and
philosopher Peter crafed put it very
well a long time ago he said quote
abortion is the antichrist's Demonic
parody of the Eucharist this is why it
uses the same holy words this is my body
with the blasphemously opposite meaning
in the Christian communion the priest
holds up the Eucharist and says this is
my body which will be given up for you
quoting Christ in abortion the left says
this is my body this is my body my
choice this even though it isn't the
woman's body it's it's a little baby
so now all the devil what a devilish
leak it's not clever it's we've we you
don't see it left you you can't
understand what you're doing but we do
see it and a lot of people have seen
this for a long time and even as you are
now openly siding with
satanists you don't understand
what you're doing a single doctor doctor
quote unquote
a murderer in Texas who has a medical
degree
as this law was going into effect
performed 67 abortions in 17 hours
because the law was about to go into
effect and moloch was very hungry and
they needed to feed these demons the
souls and bodies of innocent children so
for 17 hours a doctor in in his or her
80s is being reported performed 67
abortions 67 people
killed in 17 hours just to get that Rush
In
before the law goes into effect the left
is is losing their minds over this over
this
seems to be relatively
minor issue it's a it's a the people of
Texas
through their Democratic process through
their representatives saying you know we
don't want to kill as many babies as
we've been doing so we're going to limit
that now in this one state it's not it's
not going into your state just in this
state and the left is focusing on this
because it is their Central Sacrament
the the sacrament of the Antichrist
they're focusing on this is though this
is
the the single gravest threat to their
entire political project maybe it is
Ellie mastal who is some talking head on
MSNBC he is now suggesting that Joe
Biden create an army of federal
Physicians to go invade Texas to kill
more babies
look I live in New York okay it is wet
right now if I was on top of my roof
kind of looking for help I would expect
the Cavalry to be coming directly right
FEMA Coast Guard Operation Dumbo Drop
somebody should be coming to get me and
in fact when it happened in Katrina and
Katrina the failure of the federal
government to go get people was viewed
as one of the biggest failures of that
of George W Bush's presidency similarly
we need to go and get women in Texas and
protect their constitutionally protected
medical rights and the way you do that
is that you deputize doctors you
federalize doctors you create through an
executive order an army of federal
doctors who are going to go into Texas
and protect the Constitution by giving
women by Consulting women about their
privacy rights and their medical history
that by by federalizing the doctor force
that would protect those abortion
providers
um from the Texas law msnb BC and and
the host Joy Reid nodding along yes wow
yes yes suggesting that Joe Biden create
a federal kill Force to invade a state
strictly for the purpose of getting he
says getting the women really means
getting the babies go get the babies
don't let those babies live
he says there's a constitutionally
protected right to abortion
obviously there is not it does not
appear in the Constitution he's
suggesting as the left is suggesting now
that this is settled law obviously it's
not settled law it's not settled at all
that's why the pro-life movement has
gained ground almost without ceasing
since Roe versus wait it's not settled
in any way
he is he is saying we need to upend the
entire constitutional order creating
this federal police force
of of Physicians
just to protect
the central sacrament of the faith
of leftism of the anti-christian faith
and Joe Biden's doing it too our devout
Catholic President
The Devout the most devout Catholic how
dare you criticize or question his
devotion
Joe Biden has switched his position
he has effectively renounced his
Catholic faith over this issue he had
been playing it a little bit cagey until
this Texas issue where he is now in
formal heresy and and in a break with
the Catholic church in 2012 Joe Biden
was asked of what's your feeling on
abortion he said well I look I
personally because I'm a Catholic I'm I
believe I'm pro-life My Religion
defines who I am and uh
I've been a practicing Catholic my whole
life
um and it is particularly informed my
social doctor Catholic Social Doctrine
talks about taking care of those who
who can't take care of themselves
people who need help
with regard to um with regard to
abortion I accept my church's position
on abortion as a what we call they feed
a doctorate
life begins at conception that's the
church's judgment I accept it in my
personal life
until last week when Joe Biden came out
and said I do not agree with that the
church says that life begins a
conception I do not agree with that
I do not agree with that so Joe Biden
comes out he says my My Religion my
faith
defines my public life and he's right
he's right
but the faith is not Catholicism it's
not Christianity
it's leftism
you know with all of the encroachments
of all these crazy institutions the
government a lot of people want to be
able to just do some simple things
themselves when you want to do it
yourself I strongly recommend you check
out rockauto.com when you need a part
for your car or truck you have two
options and only two options so let me
lay them out for you you can either
go to the brick and mortar store drive
there it takes 15-20 minutes wait in
line it's another 10 minutes wait for
the guy to try to first of all Hound you
with questions that you're not going to
know the answer to then go into the back
look for the part they're not going to
have the part there's too many parts to
have then they go online probably to
rockauto.com they order the part you
wait another week or so and then you pay
twice as much that's option one or
option two you just go to rockauto.com
family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years same low
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers
always reliably low no gimmicks a
catalog so simple to navigate even I can
do it what are you going to pick option
one or option two I
you're an intelligent person if you're
listening to this show you're an
intelligent person go for option two go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car tracking
the right Knolls can a wlas in there how
did you hear about this box so they know
that we sent you Joe Biden in 2012 said
I agree with my church life begins at
conception Joe Biden in 2015 reaffirms
this I believe that life begins at the
moment of conception I'm prepared to
accept a feed a Doctrine on a whole
range of issues as a Catholic um even
though as you know Aquinas argued about
and Sumo theologic about human life and
being well then it occurs I'm prepared
to accept as a matter of faith my wife
and I my family the issue of of of of of
abortion for what I'm not prepared to do
is impose a rigid View
precise View
rigid sounds pejorative a precise view
that is born out of my faith
on other people who are equally
God-fearing
equally as committed to life equally is
committed to the sanctity of life and uh
I'm prepared to accept that the moment
of conception of human life and being
but I'm not I'm not prepared to say that
to other Godfrey non-god-free people
that have a different View
now this argument never made any sense
because he's saying I believe I Joe
Biden using all the faculties that I
have at my disposal I believe that life
begins a conception and if you commit an
abortion you are committing murder and
you're murdering innocent people
but I'll I'll allow it
I believe that I believe that but I
don't really believe that I believe that
I believe it's tantamount to murder if
you commit an abortion but I don't but
not really though right you can't he
contradicts himself and this this began
with Mario Cuomo Andrew Cuomo's father
when he was governor of New York and he
was nominally a Catholic but he had to
go along with his new Faith which is
leftism and he had to create a way for
for Democrats to have both sides of the
issue and so what he decided was the way
to do it is to say I'm personally
against abortion
but
as a political matter I would never
impose my faith well no you are you're
put to have legal abortion you're
imposing your new faith leftism on many
Christians and Jews and Muslims and
other people who oppose abortion so you
are you're imposing a faith you you
there is no neutrality here
and you're making a decision but Joe
Biden doesn't even do that anymore last
week he came out and said I do not agree
with the position
that life begins at conception I do not
agree with the position of the Catholic
church because
frankly I think that the whole leftist
argument of I'm personally against
abortion but politically I'm for
abortion never made any sense
just means you're lying somewhere you're
either lying to yourself or you're lying
to the public it's if you hold those
contradictory views at the same time
so now he renounces
the faith that we are told he's devoted
to and he accepts the real Faith the
thing we have to remember about all this
is and then we'll move on to demon Gods
I don't want to focus too much on the
satanists I also we have to get to the
demon gods that the California students
are now being told to worship not that's
not an exaggeration but it is worth
pointing out
human sacrifice
is not just some weird thing that
happened in a few places a long time ago
Human Sacrifice is part of human culture
it has happened everywhere it has
happened virtually at all at all times
with very few exceptions
one of those exceptions is the Christian
West
you see this in the Old Testament in the
Hebrew Bible
the Israelites
come into territories where there is
widespread human sacrifice and then they
put a stop to that
in
Christianity when Christianity has
spread to other places and other
cultures they've put a stop to that sort
of thing
but the reason that there is human
sacrifice I mean there are lots of
writings about this I'm particularly
fond of those of Renee Gerard who I'm
reading right now who says that the
sacrifice memetic violence is the term
that he uses is just it's the only way
that cultures can restore peace that
that rivalries gin up you know in in
cultures brothers killing brothers cane
killing Abel Romulus killing Remus the
people Banning together against a
scapegoat they need to let out their
violence they need and and when you when
you commit a sacrifice initially human
sacrifices then in some cases replaced
by animal sacrifices and then in
Christianity is replaced by the
sacrifice of Christ
that restores order for a period This is
why the the Aztecs actually this is why
indigenous American civilizations would
slaughter people at the consecration of
10 octetlan one of the temples in the
Americas in the the Aztec empire
they would kill 80 000 people sacrifice
80 000 people in the span of four days
to appease their demon gods they would
rip out beating hearts
hold them up and unknife still beating
and then throw the bodies down the
temple to the tune of 80 000 at a time
and now by the way I'm not joking I'm
not being hyperbolic California students
are being told to chant prayers to those
gods
on August 26th the Thomas Moore Society
wrote a letter to the state
superintendent of Public Instruction
requesting that they remove an Aztec
prayer
from the state's curriculum
now the state refused to respond to this
so now the Thomas Moore Society has
filed a lawsuit California in in March
of this year
introduced a new ethnic studies
curriculum ethnic studies is a fake
academic discipline for students who are
too stupid to study real academic
disciplines so it it but it's not just
because some students are are not
intelligent or educated enough to take
real courses it's also because the left
is trying to impose its own radical
ideology on a whole generation of
students and they're doing that in the
classrooms not just at the universities
but also in high school and middle
school and you know even further back so
they introduced this new ethnic studies
requirement
and he was promoted by a man who
believes that one way to rectify
colonialism is to support a quote
counter-genocide of quote white
Christians not a joke uh he uh
he calls on students quote
to challenge racist bigoted
discriminatory imperialist Colonial
beliefs and practices on multiple levels
and one way they're doing that
is having students chant prayers to the
Aztec gods tets caught lepoca and wheat
cell
I'm you know not pronouncing this
correctly I would assume uh this latter
God is the God of War among others and
and a god
to whom the Aztecs would sacrifice many
many people by stabbing them in the
chest and ripping out their hearts while
they were still beating and now our
students are chanting prayers to them
why why what the left is going to say is
oh Michael stop getting so hung up on
this it's not a real religious ritual
it's not like a real liturgy it's just
it's just a fun thing to explore other
cultures it's just a fun thing to chant
prayers to demon Gods sometimes but it's
not you're not really praying to the
demon gods
but you you are
you are though you are literally doing
that
and when you perform rituals
it with your bodies with your speech
with it when you when you do that that
is a religious right
it is and and you might not realize it
you might think you're being really
clever just like the Huffington Post
thinks they're being devilishly clever
it looks like we're partnering up with
satanists to preserve the sacrament the
Antichrist sacrament of abortion but
we're not really doing that we're just
we're just you know science promoters
we're just secularists we're just it's
not really satanic
which we're just sort of ironically
satanic
if you if you perform an activity or a
ritual or a right
ironically
forever and ever and ever you just keep
doing it it's no longer ironic
When you pray to demon Gods but it's
ironically but you you just you do it
you actually are doing it with you
you've actually done it you're actually
doing something this is probably not a
good idea so the the Thomas Moore
Society what they're trying to do is say
keep religion out of the schools we
can't have this prayer to the Aztec
demon Gods Human Sacrifice because you
know that that would be imposing
religion on schools and we're not
allowed to do that so let's stop that
whatever we got to do to get the demon
god prayers out of schools I guess
that's a good place to start but I don't
think this line of attack of keep
religion out of schools I don't think
it's ultimately going to be successful I
think
we need to Grapple with the much more
difficult question
But ultimately more correct one which is
acknowledging that we will have a
religion in schools all education is
oriented toward certain goals certain
ideals of ethics and morality and yes
religion metaphysics a recognition of
how the human person relates to the
world and we've got to make some choices
what kind of education are they going to
get
what kind of moral order are they
looking at
what do they believe about the human
person
that's going to require certain
religious premises
and ultimate ultimately they need to be
Christian okay because our civilization
is a Christian civilization and if we
have if we have our education ordered
toward
some different thing then it's going to
be a different civilization and it's
going to be a worse one and our kids are
going to worship demon Gods morning wire
is another great way to uh it's another
great ritual to get into
because you can get all the news in
about 15 minutes just all the facts
straight at you subscribe right now
start listening to morning wire on Apple
Spotify wherever you listen to podcasts
leave a five-star review if you like
what you hear we'll be right back with a
lot more
Jay Leno former host of The Tonight Show
longtime comedian Jay Leno is defending
cancel culture and so a lot of
conservatives are really upset at Jay
Leno but I am going to defend Jay Leno
because I also defend
cancel culture not the terrible leftist
cancel culture but the idea of cancel
culture in general here's what Jay Leno
said he said
when I do a gig in Utah and they'll go
look we don't want any drug jokes we
don't want any sex jokes I go okay I'll
take those out and I do something else
with the metoo movement all of a sudden
the sexist jokes everyone used to do you
can't do them anymore you adapt to the
circumstances you either change with the
times where you die
a lot of comedians have come out and
said enough cancel culture we should be
able to say whatever we want Jay Leno
has the much more nuanced and correct
view here
no if you go if a comedian goes and
plays a show in Utah in some devout
Mormon Enclave of Utah and he starts
doing a bunch of raunchy jokes they're
not going to land it's not going to work
and no whining about cancel culture is
ever going to make them work because
that Community has standards like just
like every Community has standards
and so
in in that hypothetical devout community
in Utah
some of the taboos involve raunchy sex
jokes
in The Devout leftist communities of New
York or Los Angeles
those taboos involve making jokes about
how men are different than women you're
not allowed to do that anymore but but
you you could make those jokes in Utah
and you can't you could make the raunchy
sex jokes in New York but there are
going to be standards and taboos
and so
when we're thinking about all of these
issues what kind of activities we're
allowed to engage in in Texas what kind
of things kids are going to be taught in
schools what kind of jokes comedians can
make
I think we've got to move past the
shallow
my freedom slogans okay we we want
freedom we love freedom we like the
tradition of freedom but we Freedom
doesn't just mean
doing whatever you want at any given
time okay that isn't no one's ever no
serious person has ever thought that
that's what freedom is certainly not the
founding of others we need to we need to
dig in much more to these harder
questions what is it that we're
pro-scribing in Texas what is it we're
not allowed to do
what is it that we're praying to in
schools what is it that our religious
education is aiming at our inevitable
religious education what is it
that is off limits even for comedians
you know what's off limits in China
right now
girly men in the movies uh September 3rd
Amazon released its remake of Cinderella
this is news to me I haven't haven't
caught the movie yet
this is featuring Billy Porter whom I've
never heard of in the role of a
genderless fairy godmother
so oh he's okay so he's a guy but he's
like a from what I take it from the
costume he's like a flamboyant
gender-bending fairy god father mother
officials in China
have called for quote
resolutely putting an end to [ __ ] men
and other abnormal Aesthetics on
television
the party also instructed entertainment
producers not to cast actors with lapsed
morals and incorrect political positions
and they're banning reality shows that
feature the children of stars are
arguing that these promote a quote
unhealthy preoccupation with vulgar
internet celebrities as well as an
admiration of wealth and celebrity
they're also they're also Banning
excessive video game use by kids
to which I would say
it doesn't sound so bad does it you know
I don't you never want to be on the side
of the Communist Party in China and I'm
not I'm not but on the broader point I
suppose I am
because what
what is really clear in China
is is something that exists in America
but people are just not clear about it
namely there actually are
standards and limits that you that are
in place
the standards and limits are just
different in America
the The Blob the liberal establishment
that runs Hollywood that the the studios
system the the not the old Studio system
but the new way that it works
is such that you really can't produce
movies that are patriotic that take a
positive view of American history that
include strong masculine men who are
good who are not toxic and women who are
womanly you're not that's not really
permitted it's all always the you know
the woman has to
can't be saved by the man anymore the
Damsel in Distress the woman has to save
herself or she has to she has to come in
and save the man even or you know the
man has to be sort of effeminate or very
toxic or it's always got to be
ideological with very few exceptions
especially these days
so what China is regressing toward I
guess you would say is maoism that Mao
did this stuff too he said now there's
going to be really rigid rules in place
about our art we don't want just pure
agent prop but we also don't want girly
men and unpatriotic themes and we don't
want all this craziness in the movies we
recognize that the culture is going to
craft the citizenry and we want to make
sure that the culture is doing a good
job
the left imported I mean they've
imported this directly from now actually
in the 1960s from China and it has
shaped the way that that leftism in
America has progressed in the ensuing
decades I write about this a lot in my
book speechless so they're right I think
we need to acknowledge that they're
right and I think we need to once again
move Beyond this really shallow language
of you do whatever you want
the government can never do anything
the and and we should never tell
Hollywood that they CA they shouldn't
make a movie you know that is
unpatriotic or anti-American or
inverting of Standards we can't do that
because everyone should be able to do
whatever they want at any given time the
politics is Downstream of culture the
politics never affects the culture as
we're often told no no
to use a line from George will actually
back when he was conservative statecraft
is soul craft yes the prevailing culture
in a society will shape the kind of
government that Society has but the
government will also shape the kind of
people
that are there we know this
conservatives admit this all the time
whenever we complain about the Great
Society and the social the governmental
upheavals of the 1960s how it destroyed
the black family what we are
acknowledging is the government can
shape the citizenry the politics can
shape the culture as well and what China
is saying is yeah we don't want all of
our men to stop being men yeah we don't
want all of our kids to waste all their
time on video games yeah we don't want
all of our citizens to hate their
country so we're going to suppress those
kinds of themes
you know in the late 1930s you had
some of the greatest films that were
ever made were all made during this
period
and
you know part of this is because of the
haze code this was an industry
self-regulating system to avoid
government censorship and so they
created their own self self-censorship
and you had all of these really really
great movies
but movies weren't always wholesome in
the past actually before the haze code
went to it into effect you had a bunch
of filthy degenerate movies I think you
may have seen a clip of of one of them
going going around the internet it kind
of became a mean meme of like all sorts
of people who look all sort of they have
all sorts of crazy problem it was called
freaks right and they'll say one of us
one of us Google gobble Google gobble
and it's just the whole point of it is
this it's supposed to be a freak Show
and you know very perverse and weird and
creepy and a lot of movies were like
that back then and then there was some
self-regulation and you had really high
works of art and frankly a culture that
I think was healthier
and now we're regressing toward that so
I'm not saying we got a you know copy
China exactly the problem with China is
it's I mean and they're using this kind
of language they want to be
revolutionary they want to be socialist
they was they want to use the government
to impose that maoist cultural
revolution once again we don't want to
do that but we need to recognize that
the government and the culture and the
institutions are going to shape people
so we should use that for good
traditional American and speaking of
fictional media
you've probably seen this story
over the weekend but just just a quick
note to remind you not to believe what
you read in the media
Rolling Stone headline One hospital
denies Oklahoma doctor's story of
ivermectin overdoses causing ER delays
for gunshot victims
that's the new headline
that's the new headline
the original headline was
gunshot victims left waiting as horse
dewormer overdoses overwhelm Oklahoma
hospitals doctor says huh that's weird
it's the same article why they have
different headlines
because the story was completely fake
and this story when he was in Rolling
Stone it was picked up by My
Doppelganger over at MSNBC Rachel Maddow
it was picked up on local news this went
everywhere gunshot victims are left
waiting because idiot rube conservatives
are eating a horse dewormer and
poisoning themselves Rachel Maddow could
patience overdosing on Ivermectin
backing up rural Oklahoma hospitals and
ambulances quote the scariest one I've
heard of and seen is people coming in
with vision loss he said Rachel Maddow
tweeting this around
but then Rolling Stone had changed the
headline because it was fake it's
completely fake
and this story was based on on one
doctor's claims and the doctor
doesn't even work at the hospital
anymore here's the statement from the
hospital
although Dr Jason and michalea is not an
employee of NHS Sequoia he is affiliated
with the Medical Staffing group that
provides coverage for our emergency room
with that said Dr michalea has not
worked at our Salas law location in over
two months NHS Sequoia has not treated
any patients due to complications
relating to taking Ivermectin this
includes not treating any patients
forevermectin overdose all patients who
have visited her emergency room have
received medical attention as
appropriate our hospital has not had to
turn away any patients seeking emergency
care we want to assure our community
that our staff is working hard to
provide quality Health Care to all
patients we appreciate the opportunity
to clarify this issue and as always we
value our community's support
in other words the story
was completely
fake every aspect of it was completely
fake but it made it around the world
it's not the only one it's not the only
fake Ivermectin story The Associated
Press
here we are it's amazing I mean they've
got more and more and more
versions of this story floating around
but here's from the Associated Press
they claim 70 percent of calls to
Mississippi Poison Control were about
Ivermectin overdoses
70 percent
wow those idiots taking that horse
dewormer correction in an article
published August 23rd about people
taking livestock medicine to try to
treat coronavirus the Associated Press
erroneously reported based on
information provided by Mississippi
Department of Health
and 70 of recent calls to Mississippi
Poison Control Center were from people
who had ingested Ivermectin to try and
treat coven 19. State epidemiologist Dr
Paul Byers said Wednesday the number of
calls to poison control about Ivermectin
was two percent
was two percent he said of the calls
that were about Ivermectin 70 percent
were people were by people who had
ingested the veterinary version of the
medicine
headlines story on page A1 70 of poison
control calls are Ivermectin overdoses
idiot horse dewormer people
correction on page z1000 that no one's
going to read actually it was two
percent and actually it wasn't even two
percent it was seventy percent of two
percent
that we're about overdoses
complete complete lie a complete lie
that very few people are going to find
out about if you listen to this show
you'll know that that story was a lie
but if you listen to this show you
already know that this story was a lie
you already knew that it was very that
the media were not to be trusted in the
Ivermectin stuff is a complete joke
the the attacks on Ivermectin
but I'm sorry to say I mean look a lot
of people listen to this show hundreds
of thousands of people listen to this
show
but there are hundreds of millions of
people in the country
and the left controls the means of
communication to the vast majority of
them here's another fake story a
perfectly healthy 13 year old boy died
of Coronavirus
this is a very sad story because a 13
year old boy actually did die of the
coronavirus and the reason the story is
being pushed around perfectly healthy 13
year old boy
the reason it's being pushed around is
to impel
young people and children to take this
vaccine that they really don't need to
take they're not at a statistically very
great risk of dying from coronavirus and
there are questions about the
coronavirus about the vaccine rather
will it inflame their hearts there was a
13 year old boy whose heart became
inflamed and he died just days after
receiving the second dose of the vaccine
so there are a lot of questions so why
should we make kids who aren't really at
Great risk of coronavirus why would we
make them take this experimental drug
well because a perfectly healthy 13 year
old died except the perfectly healthy 13
year old was 300 pounds
he had huge comorbidities of course he
was at much greater risk it's horribly
sad now the mother is calling for
mandatory vaccines for all the kids
fake news this is what the fake news is
and if you point this out you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist
you know you know the difference between
conspiracy theory and the truth we've
said it before on this show about 12 to
16 months it seems these days
but they don't know they don't know it
gets back to the the Texas abortion law
it gets back to siding with the actual
satanic temple it gets back to making
kids pray to Aztec demon gods
the left doesn't know
there's a there's a woman who a doctor
uh Cass Dr something Cass she was the
woman who sounded like a demon tweeting
out the other day saying give me your
children I'm I'll I'll tell me if you
want an abortion in Texas I'll figure it
out I'll kill your children don't just
let me do it and I said this woman
sounds like a demon she wrote Into Me
she said Michael instead of making fun
of me just invite me on the show we'll
discuss it I invited her on the show we
haven't heard back of course for days
now we haven't heard back of course not
she has no idea what we think
she has no idea what she's doing she has
no idea the reality of the things that
she just like
especially on these issues just like the
entire left
historical perspective is very helpful
when you're considering the propriety of
Aztec demon god prayers and satanists
and even on economic matters there's a
headline
came out last week and I want to make
sure we get to it a shocking headline
quote an Oregon McDonald's is so
desperate for workers it hung a huge
Banner outside calling on 14 year olds
to apply
my gosh they must really be desperate 14
year olds working at a fast food joint
why that's
exactly the kind of person who worked at
the fast food joint even 20 30 years ago
but no longer
how old were you when you got your first
job I was 14. what was your first job my
first job was at a fast food joint I was
an artist
I've always worked in the Arts I was a
Sandwich Artist at Subway
that that used to be the point of these
jobs maybe not the manager of the
franchise or something like that but the
people flipping burgers
used to be a job for teenagers
then
because we just opened the borders of
our country and flooded it with
Way disproportionately low-skilled Labor
a lot of people
who were adults in their 30s 40s 50s
crowded out the teenagers
in that in that labor market so now you
go into a fast food restaurant
and it's very rarely is it someone who's
14 or 15. that was just that was a big
change in the way that our economy
functioned now we have a labor shortage
because the government is paying people
to sit on their couches and so that you
can't hire anyone
even today I was going through a fast
food place to get a little breakfast and
they were extremely short staffed they
couldn't get people to work there so
there's big signs out from please we're
hiring please come come work here
lots of
there are lots of unintended
consequences to these leftist policies
okay and they don't see it happening
they say okay we opened the floodgates
of our Southern border that's good for
everyone that's good that's
compassionate well it's not good for the
kids who now don't get job experience
okay it's not good for
the health of the American economy I
think in the long run you
start partnering with satanists and
Aztec demon gods
that oh it's just nice oh it's just
multiculturalism oh it's we're just
following the science oh it's just
tactical oh it's just this it's probably
not good in the long run
to have these sorts of occult
rituals be elevated as your National
religion
probably not good at all
this actually brings me to Labor Day
just a point on this especially on these
14 and 15 year olds at McDonald's who by
the way now they've shown up McDonald's
has hired 14 and 15 year olds and it
turns out they're great employees
because they're young they're full of
energy they're eager to learn they're
very malleable and they're doing a good
job and we should have more of that in
this country uh speaking of holidays
yesterday was Labor Day and I know there
were a lot of conservatives who came I
mean we even made some jokes about it
here at the daily wire but there are a
lot of conservatives who said this is a
communist holiday and we hate it we
don't want anything to do with it and
that that isn't true it's not a
communist holiday
it is a holiday that was created
actually to undermine the Communist
holiday of Mayday that was the
international communist holiday and when
the United States pushed for Labor Day
yes it was certainly influenced by the
labor movements and it was influenced by
the Socialists and the Communists but it
was actually a way of of undermining
that and I just think there there has
been a running theme on the right for
the past 30 years or so 20 30 years that
we hate labor That We're the Party of
the billionaires and the plutocrats and
the CEOs and forget about Labor we hate
American labor let's Outsource
everything let's flood the country with
cheap labor and to bring to lower wages
for Americans in the working class and
that's just crazy that's not a good idea
first of all the plutocrats and the
billionaires and all of them hate us
generally speaking they don't like us
the companies that are shipping jobs
overseas hate America they have no
loyalty to it the Republican party will
be a working class party we are if
you're talking about regular normal
Americans who work regular normal jobs I
don't think they're particularly
attracted to BLM burning their country
down the LGBT agenda but pushing drag
queen Story Hour in schools or radical
anti-American revolutionaries who want
to tear down George Washington so we
actually could get
American labor well I think we've got to
adapt and recognize now we appreciate
American labor actually we like this is
a good thing we want to actually keep
out some foreign labor so that we can
beef up our own
our own base our own American people
speaking of holidays this is another one
I can't let go
the Boston Marathon
has just issued a big apology the Boston
Athletics Association
issued a big apology because they
scheduled the Boston Marathon on an
important holiday
they scheduled the Boston Marathon on
indigenous people's day
you know indigenous peoples stay that
totally real thing not that not just a
fake thing
I know when is indigenous people's day I
looked it up it's October 9th
I said no that can't be indigenous
people's day that's Columbus Day
Columbus Day oh right indigenous
people's day is was invented by the libs
because they hate Columbus so much
because Columbus is the representative
of Western Civilization
and the Boston Athletics Association is
not not apologizing that they put their
marathon on Columbus Day which is a good
holiday about a great man
got an ethnic component too the Italians
love Columbus Day because Columbus was
Italian but it's a broader holiday for
Western Civilization discovery of the
new world
no it's they're apologizing because it's
offensive to
Indians and people who don't think that
the United States is a legitimate
country and think that we stole
everyone's land and we shouldn't be here
in the first place and America is just a
colonial evil awful project
who cares who cares
is what people who cares if it's
indigenous people's day or Columbus Day
or if the marathon's there look both
sides are crazy about this it's not a
big deal right
the left carers the left cares why who
cares about the pronouns who cares about
this who cares who cares about the
holidays the left cares that's why
they're putting so much energy and
effort into renaming the holidays
because a holiday is a holy day
who cares what statues we have up who
cares what prayers the kids are reciting
in schools as part of their
multiculturalism curriculum who cares
the left cares why does the left care
because
the holidays that we keep holy the
prayers that we chant the rituals that
we engage in will Define our culture and
our politics and our religion
and
if you do it enough if you just do it
enough and you're mindless about it you
just do it because the left leads you
there and you don't fight back
you're not even going to know it's
happening and you're going to wake up
one day and you're going to be
worshiping Satan and the demon gods and
you can say how did we get here how did
we get here because we didn't care
enough and we didn't fight back I'm
Michael no sister Michael knows y'all
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
Borah our technical director is Austin
Stevens supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Nica Geneva Michael
Knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. on the Matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture Faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show